I'm expecting an accurate representation
of our country I'm not I'm expecting to
get a lot of stereotypical ideas of what
Australian food is I just kept hearing
about bloomin onions steak this is what
we're gonna judge Outback Steakhouse on
it smells delicious
I actually just bent the fork trying to
this is a normal fork and this is Cal
this is tryin Outback Steakhouse steak
there's a good steak this is not a good
steak it's so dry stick to ease it up
ruin my dinner oh it smells like
barbecue sauce
it's American barbecue sauce I can tell
the difference it's literally just
chicken with barbecue sauce ah that's
good but it's like not a straight then
I'm just gonna sorry haha what a good is
rain sauce bit of tomato sauce being
tomato not catch up tomorrow
this is what we call a prawn in
Australia not a shrimp
it's a bloody proof of bloody fraud mmm
whines it tastes like a macaroon I'm
sorry oh why is everything in this
country says wait everything we bought
into we taste America there was way too
much better but that's a definite thumbs
down he ruined the prawn we would just
do straight shrimps we wouldn't have
anything you maybe have like a little
bit of bread with butter to the side
okay ribs are really a big thing in
Australia no they're definitely not I'm
starting to feel like this Outback
Steakhouse is just like American steak
houses it smells good smells like meat
no I want to live in it it's probably my
favorite thing so far
but it's not Australian I'm probably
gonna be crucified by saying that this
is actually really good like you don't
really get ribs that often so this is
like a cyclone Ollie's a treat
what's this blue is that hold on hold on
wait that's one on you Oh deep-fried
heaven you know what I've never seen any
I couldn't remove a fried onion its
bloomin ridiculous give it up now for
you Ken it's actually pretty good
I kind of don't mind it in a weird way I
feel like if I had any more of that I
would regret it to the day I died
Oh God all week people have been saying
you're gonna have a blooming blooming in
an onion or whatever and you're gonna
love it you're gonna love it how wrong
they were I'm really sad we're so
misrepresented right now if you want to
claim us for this we're happy with that
I didn't expect it to taste Australian
well I expected it to taste okay they've
got all this American product and
they've just slapped a big fake
Australian kind of like you're gonna be
Australian down restaurant I would like
to know who clear the menu the founders
of Epic Steakhouse have never been to
Australia it's a lie yeah didn't want to
nip over for a bit of research oh that
makes sense now oh yes I gots like me
opening a Turkish restaurant we do it
over I know something like I'm course we
do from everyone in Australia to the
people with Outback Steakhouse before
due respect jump on us pour upon it I
made are you 13 hours away okay just
stop serving that onion thing what's the
slogan for Outback Steakhouse again look
at right now
what Canada 146 self ran for hot I think
it's actually Ryan